olha só tomaram já estava em um carro
roubaram um carro que é isso do roubar o
carro pessoal que fala da crise muito
bem-vindos é mais um vídeo pessoal eu
estou doente
hoje eu tô indo porque o irã não tem
como se fosse uma corrida de lindolfo e
então estava muito vento estava muito
muito quente muito frio ao mesmo tempo
eu fiquei doente tosse não é falso não
dói mesmo muito e é que ela toque bem
profunda e foi mesmo o pulmão assembléia
por mão que agora tudo no quarto indo eu
estou aqui só para pegar a doença é
também quer que eu fique doente na não
seja eleito tais aqui porque pela
primeira vez tony allen para o coronel
sementeira
não não posso beijar por beijar meu pai
lá o windows se inscrevam 3 milhões
na quarta vamos também as compras mundo
comprou que olha aí manchete nova tebas
ficar bem bonita em que doença é doença
do meu quarto amazônia como é que eu
tenho um quarto deusa olha isso papel
higiênico pé da cama window porque eles
o window pela higiene cola da cana
sim sim sim
no entanto os dois é isso que acontece
o mundo não está a fim de evitar toda
renda lhe saviola ainda não para o
género do im
olha só a casa da índia também está toda
suja as ruas bem isso acho bem isso
sustenta sido maior no chão sou maia
lixo
já não tenho não
já não sou jemics já não sou de mim
muito longe eu voltar vou voltar pro
portugal
vamos a isto o senhor foi um tijolo em
estúdio é muito gostoso que é correta na
decisão com doença muito bom para o
porto na obra
não abra a porta a essa porcaria aí mas
não só contar o meu quarto tá bem
limpinha agora é que já não tem muito
futuro kaká xuxa nua irmã doente mandou
em si mesmo e não só para além de
corrida que lindo gol que nós fizemos eu
tenho é que se tenha um pouquinho quando
estava no brasil portanto uma
oportunidade de ver melhor as coisas e
conseguir participar em alguns jogos em
alguns obstáculos lá portanto vejam aí
tá muito bom aí outra coisa o windows
que se esquece corrida de carros golf
havia uma aposta de 500 dólares
assim o véu nobel nada não dão nada
ele sabe que um sinal de força dos 509 m
só vou até o fim que ganhou a corrida
daquele rock no rio othon ainda sair
após aplicar um lindo gol o meu quintal
aqui e ainda carrinho bem gostoso olha
aí o meu é maior na pessoa mais gordo e
não vamos fazer uma corrida
agora usa just usa que isso é mais
bonito mas isto é muito mais velha de
tempos atrás vale a pena trazer anda
muito mais obras não só potência igreja
pensa muito mais
então espero fazer mais duas com kaká a
fazer a troca e tem uma atração do angry
birds meu é muito louco só vou entrar
aqui sua mãe nilva um só isso funciona
mesmo
mas falta um pássaro depois passa existe
algum passo que os passos de percebam
como simplesmente não há aqui um
parceiro mas vamos fazer as coisas só
isto é uma pirâmide é uma pista do
assassino escolhido e eu vou contar
agora vai ter que uma cobra gigante o
inimigo mas vamos passar por ela aí está
um labirinto e aquino assim a calma
calma campo tem que ser porque meu
pessoal está muito confuso tem um
caminho aqui e outro caminho aqui ok eu
acho que é por este ao o está em ordem
o leite uma escada que eu vou subir é eu
espero não queria aqui é tem uma cobra
gigante então assim está a gostar
bom-bom rabo rápida porque quando só vai
ter que tirar agora como é que eu vou
fazer isso
eu sou muito burro olhei é muito
apertado só é muito a plataforma eu vou
conseguir vou conseguir porque eu sou
muito bem tem um lado agora temos que
ressaltar
agora temos que entrar nessa pirâmide
construída que eu acho que o espírito
que só vou precisar da ajuda de alguém
filmar isso né colega de profissão isso
mesmo mostra muito mal os nossos filhos
só para lá disse que é seguro que eu
consegui tirar agora é muito louco só
aqui também tem um mapa do super mario e
eu vou fazer muito rápido
agora tenho aqui um labirinto ocorrer
sob o lema meu deus tem um inimigo aqui
morre inimigo mora só tem aqui muito
tranqüilo em si eu vou saltar estrella
234 conseguir só vejam só como parte da
cor é muito lindo eu vou subir lá acima
eu acho que não vou conseguir porque eu
sou bem gordo mas vamos tentar eu vou
tentar seguir nessa escala aí meu deus
solo com muito alto sério tudo muito
óbvio eu voltei melhor cheira não
conseguiu ir lá acima
[Risadas]
porque aí não só esses cada banda muito
do com medo os jogos que eu sei que deve
estate então as mensagens agora posso
falar muita coisa de música e ainda vão
demorar mais primeiro e que temos uma
das melhores partes que é um disco muito
bem e gourmet square porque não sabem
por dentro e por fora isto é muito
inspirado no mercado da ribeira portanto
se quiserem comer aqui é muito gostoso
eu já me gusta isso que vocês estão a
ver tudo até ao fundo é rockstreet a
áfrica cada casinha dela se apresenta
cada sítio do continente africano é
muito louco para sua casinha diferentes
são bem-vindas mesmo aqui tem uma girafa
solicitem marquinhos logo que a frente
tem um adn gigantones lago azul é muito
grande quem me dera ter uma piscina em
casa né pela gigante e vejam só a vista
ao fundo muito lendo essa vista e
principalmente quando soltava pipa que
irão lhe fica muito ruim de bola o faraó
que o faraó palavra está tudo bem em
cima em pedra como eu fazia isso este
aqui é o palco aqui né é um bom
paulistão eo pior é ver este que também
gostou muito e jipes e olha que o gato o
que isto do que isto que não sei mexer
vai tem muita casa séria tem muita casa
aqui esta aqui é isso é isso que tem um
euro e meio se eu fosse um membro da
casa era o nome eu tenho certeza que
aqui atrás de mim esta que esse gigante
é o digitalks day é o palco onde tudo
junto para mostrar este passo é dedicada
tudo continuar online ao vivo nem eu já
tive a oportunidade para que em cima
quero ver é muito grande e que tem uma
coisa muito interessante que é o ovo
famosa gestão todas as mãos todos os
artistas que já porque o passado mas
faltam ainda bem que aqui uns passinhos
já premiada já pra mim o que o povo de
eletrônica onde o pessoal passa aqui
música eletrônica e provavelmente eu vou
estar aqui e só aqui é o que time
português que aqui no brasil olha só eu
já tive lá em cima como o rei sol e
beber um vinho já sabe sempre onde eu
vou te comer né pessoal aqui atrás
minhoca que traz tem roda gigante que eu
também vou andar portanto não perca os
próximos vídeos e vai ser muito o que
são e se mostrou em cima do palco mundo
é muito grande tem muita kadafi para lá
inclusive que corrida que lindo gol
folga já tá ali brom
agora é a nossa vez que um dia eu estava
com muita confiança e acreditar e
confiar que o carro bom e agora lá 321
vai só vai sair
ontem 1º o elenco do treinador já foi já
fui mas já fui eu estava atrás de um
tamanho atraso
olha é isso muito é e já foi já não não
esqueça o acidente
ganhei só acho que é o que interessa
mesmo é o bicho falando comigo tá bem
mais atrás ou em 2010 muito por dizer
que eu ganhei colhida e quer fazer a
troca
bora bora bora olha só roubaram já
estava em um carro roubaram um carro que
é isso
roubar o carro não acontecer o carro
buscar só vamos lá então para a segunda
ronda o windows natalino camping da obra
agora na fase vamos ver se tá fácil eo
conduziram à detenção ou perder é muito
puro mas vamos lá
a agenda porém 3211 vai assim estava em
off o texto ganhou nenhum caso 321 vai
assim assim
portanto a portaria ganho ganho ganho
esata frente em poder e que achou de
cachorro
como assim eu já estava muito à frente
escalando muito podre só injusto é
injusto carne é realmente o caso dela é
melhor
é muito injusto burro
o time mantenha russa deu esse carro é
muito ponto não há bolha só olha só o
que é isso fica um igual mas claramente
diferenciado clara milan e claramente
não é tão fácil de entender que não
fosse nosso mel